[Music]
there's no way this episode is as
interesting as the last one but I'm
still gonna try
so first the architecture in the dancers
room is flammable and not just from her
weapons but from ours as well this fire
spreading effect exists all throughout
lothric castle and it stops when you
reach the Grand Archives and then it
starts again in the twin princes boss
fight on two chairs in particular these
ones the ones on their sides I spent a
lot of time hitting chairs with a torch
today and to be honest I wish this
mechanic was built into way more wooden
structures maybe with the ability to
deal damage if enemies got too close to
the fire I think the game could really
benefit from more environmental effects
more distraction effects things like
that second do you remember this moment
in one of the really old Dark Souls
trailers an elite Knight does the quiet
resolve emote as they walk away and this
same a moat is given to us by unring in
Dark Souls 3 a character who wears the
elite Knights set and really embodies
that same sentiment that same courage
because honoree is a character who
dedicatedly pursues her and Horace's
quest against Aldridge even after
Horace's passing third after we killed
the abyss watchers walk would a fellow
unhindered he thanks us for helping them
find their final resting place and after
they're dead Hawk would the crestfallen
looks away and leaves to find his
purpose we see him next outside the
fight with Osiris and I bet this is
where he comes across the way of the
Dragon II mode and then Hawk wood can be
summoned atop the arch dragon peak and
you might not have done this with him
but he actually performs the way of the
Dragon emote here obtaining his own
twinkling dragon headstone while you
obtained the twinkling dragon tosser
stone after talking with Andre awk wood
can be confronted beside the corpses of
his fellow Legionnaires where you fight
for the title of the true dragon
and most curiously if you lose here
hawkwood will actually take the
twinkling dragon torso stone from your
inventory until you managed to defeat
him and steal it back I thought it was
really interesting that the game really
shows you his path throughout the world
moving on for number four it's obvious
that the nameless king is Quinn's
firstborn the God of War who led the
Warriors of sunlight but as an awesome
piece of extra evidence did you notice
that the sunlight metal sigil is all
throughout arch dragon peak printed on
these silver plates another thing I
discovered when going over character
dialogue did you know that bloodless has
some seriously tricky to receive
dialogue if you kill him and then reload
the area and go close to him then he'll
be asleep he'll be dreaming and he'll be
muttering this ah it seems you to the
bone yes but he's helped me be done with
me no God no I cannot bear it
make a pun I must have dozed a while is
he having nightmares about the time he
linked the fire maybe interestingly if
you initiate this post-death dialogue
with him after you defeat the Dragon
Slayer Armour then he says this as well
see not I am a lord are we playing
be like but I shot another one forgive
me oh please I am not to blame
I'm not Lilith is a fascinating
character there's surely more to him
that needs to be revealed he's this Lord
who exists in an alternate version of a
shrine where he states that he painted a
new vision of the world
and while he's really proud of how he
linked the flame he also displays this
supreme amount of guilt and pain in his
nightmares something is going on here
and I hope it's elucidated in the DLC
six true two patches deep law his
dialogue changes when you start the game
as a cleric every rotten clerics dream
right next I'm sure by now a lot of you
know that the calamity ring can be
obtained by performing the way of the
Dragon emote at this statue but more
importantly do you think that they're
poking fun at the players in the
description this ring has no useful
powers and is merely a symbol of dragon
worship a thing quietly passed down
amongst its most fervent adherents some
of whom become convinced the task has
been bestowed upon them as a sacred duty
this is a ring that makes you take
double damage and in the last episode we
talked a little bit about how they might
be doing this same thing with the
pendant where they poked fun at people
who are convinced that these items mean
something and I bet they're doing it
here as well because a lot of people
thought this ring meant something in
Dark Souls 1 but it didn't for number 8
did you ever pay attention to this
corpse dead at the first bonfire in the
profaned capital surrounded by ladders
its letter Smith Gilligan from Dark
Souls 2 a beloved and complex character
who sold ladders that helped you access
a place that you could just drop down
into yeah he's pretty forgettable
anyway him being here is pretty funny
actually once again he's surrounded by
ladders and at least some of them are
useful this time for number nine I'd be
surprised if you managed to find a bunch
of items that appear on corpses after
you've killed their corresponding NPCs
for example the pale shade set appears
in filing shrine
if you've defeated this invader in
Ferren keep and Aerith ill Kirk's barbed
set appears near Rosario if you kill his
phantom in the cathedral hovel set
appears near the stray demon once the
hovel knight is dead in the real world
Podrick set is found upon his corpse in
the pit of Hallows after Cirrus is
questline and Syria's sunless talisman
is found on a grave outside our shrine
once a quest is complete her
grandfather's shield can also be found
here and finally one of my favorite sets
which is cratons mirror chain set is
found upon the bridge after you kill him
in syria's world and your own as well
I'll leave wiki links to all of these in
the description below if you want to
find them for the Lord of Hallows ending
you sacrifice your fellow uncondensed
for your own but did you know that
unreasoning cutscene you can spot him or
her here and additionally some people
have stated that an reappears without
armor for them in a hollow state but I
was never able to reliably replicate
this glitch but anyway the implications
from this are that Omri lives on if you
want to call being Hollow living so we
started last episode off with the
discovery that the dances sound clips
could be reversed so that you could hear
their original sound and now a week or
two later user Center is back with more
fascinating sound findings and I just
can't help but talk about these again so
the crystal sages for example sound like
they're saying release me now when this
clip is reversed
the Deacons sound like they're in a lot
of pain and this is what it sounds like
when hundreds of curses are stuffed
inside a spirit tree and there are a
bunch more creepy haunting and
illuminating sound effects that you can
listen to so go and check out that link
in the description for 12 did you know
that you can combine the 2 swords of the
twin princes of lothric to create the
twin princes great sword this requires
new game+ and if you have both of the
swords from two twin princes souls then
just bring them to Lilith until
transpose them together within the
webinar of this new great sword is both
the sacred light of lothric and the
flame of Laurium next there are quite a
few npcs that have hard-to-find endings
to their quest first did you know that
all bec can appear in the ground
archives if you purchase all of his
spells he can even help you with the
lothric boss fight if you do this and
afterwards you'll find his corpse
sitting at a table beside these
candlesticks scholars also in the grand
archives is gray rats corpse if you
manage to keep him alive after his
outing to Erath he'll third if you only
purchase light miracles from arena then
she'll eventually become a mute fire
keeper moving to the bottom of the tower
to the side of the filing shrine and she
can even level you up if you desire
that's some
be your strength lastly at the end of
honorees quest to kill Aldrich Henry
hollows her Duty fulfilled now heed his
little warning from this little Lord
seek not the girl she knows her fate
what will become of her upon her duties
end she would not wish to follow her
after receiving her sword she left with
Lilith Henry can be followed to her
grave in two places if you told her
where you found Horus then she will
decide that her grave should be beside
his and if you never told her where to
find Horus then she will hallow atop
this lonely hill outside the Cathedral
of the deep a place that probably has
some meaning to her because this is
where her early life was within the
Cathedral of the deep the 14 did you
know that it's possible to stagger your
to the point where you can perform a
critical attack this reminds me so much
of blood-borne especially if you do it
with a fist weapon like the user
Cleopatra who pointed this out the other
week
4:15 I want to give a bit of a teaser
for an upcoming video that I'm planning
on doing in collaboration with
everyone's favorite translator law
master no joke we've done a few
translation videos in the past in the
research for the angels of lothric and
the hollows of Londo video we discovered
that ureas line actually translates more
accurately to Qarth your dying wish
wasn't done so does this mean that calf
the primordial serpent that many assumed
was immortal might actually be dead
this Japanese is drastically different
from the English at any rate so all this
and more will come out in a full
translation video where we go over the
fascinating little discrepancies between
the English and the Japanese but we
might wait until the DLC comes out I
think because then we'll have access to
all of the descriptions but I'd love it
if you could throw low master Nadja a
follow on twitter or something he's been
this huge help to me and he's currently
working on an indie game project that
looks really interesting so far but
thank you for watching this one guys I
think we're finally ahead of schedule
with videos a bit now there should
always be a video out for patrons
whenever I release a new video so become
a patron if you want a bit of early
access but yeah hopefully I can get back
into more of a regular schedule now for
once in my life thanks for watching and
I'll see you next time